[Music]  a hidden keep elite not taken retrace  your steps escape your past and the key  will be yours at last what part of your  past are you trying to escape a ledee  [Music]  this is the Oasis a whole virtual  universe you can do anything be anyone  without going anywhere at all the Oasis  was created by James Halliday  and what he left behind changed  everything a contest three impossible  challenges the first to finish gets  complete control of the Oasis which  means complete control of the future  contest has got to be about connecting  with someone connecting to the world so  we take it together  sure  [Music]  [Music]  save the Oasis safety ball  are you ready  that's better I'll wave to you from the  finish line McFly  [Music]  you